This example, a stub AS, in this case 30308, might
receive IP address space, say, 12.20.249/24,
from one of its providers, such as AT&T, which happens to own
12.0.0.0/8. Now in this case, AS 30308
wants to be multihomed. In other words, it wants to be reachable via
two upstream Internet service providers. In this
diagram, the two Internet service providers are AT&T
and Verizon. To be reachable by both of these ISPs, AS 30308 has to advertise
its prefix, which it received from AT&T. By a both AT&T and Verizon. The problem
occurs when AT&T and Verizon want to advertise
that prefix to the rest of the internet.
Well unfortunately, although AT&T might like to
aggregate this prefix as I previously described, it
can't. If it did, Verizon would still
be advertising the longer /24 by it's upstream
link. And because it's longest prefix match,
all of the traffic would then arrive via
the Verizon link regardless of what AS 30308
wanted to have happened to that incoming traffic.
As a result, both AT&T and Verizon must advertise the same /24 to the rest of
the internet. This results in an explosion of
/24s, in the global internet routing table. You
can imagine, that if a lot of stub
AS's, wanted to be multihomed, then suddenly, we've
got a lot more /24s, in the global
routing table, than might otherwise exist without multihoming.